Alright Michael, so see if you can tell me where we're
going here. So, just as a reminder I've erased a bunch of
stuff so I can make some room. We're trying to maximize
this cost function, J prime sub pi, which is basically the sum
of the mutual information between every single feature and its parents.
And I want to point out that that actually induces a graph. In
fact a fully connected graph. So here, I've drawn a bunch of
nodes as part of a graph, and all the edges between them.
Each one of these nodes is going to represent a feature,
an X of I and what's going to go on the edges,
is going to be the mutual information between them. So,
I know have a fully connected graph, which has the mutual
information between each pair of nodes. All in squared edges,
and I want to find a sub graph of this graph,
in particular a tree. That maximizes these sums. So, any
ideas how I do that, Michael? First off, does that make
sense what I just said?
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah, I mean it's, it's
very interesting right. So we're trying to pick, each,
each time we pick an edge, it's actually saying
that what we, we're going to care about the relationship
between this pair of variables. And we're only
allowing edges. We're not allowing, because they, they, that
involves 2 nodes. We're not getting sets of 3,
or 5, or however many nodes larger than that.
>> Mm-hm. And so what we want, is we want to
be considering a subset of edges, that form a tree,
that has the highest total information content. This is correct.
>> And that's a minimum spanning tree.
>> Well, not quite.
>> That's a maximum spanning tree.
>> That's exactly right. It turns out that finding the
tree consistent with this graph, such that this is true,
is in fact the same thing as finding the maximum
spanning tree. Which we all vaguely remember from our algorithms class.
>> So you said, it was terribly painful, but it's actually not.
This is a
>> No, I said, it's, it's terribly easily painful.
>> So, that's really neat. We turn to
problem of finding the best distribution, and in
particular the best dependency tree, independent of the
true underlying distribution, I want to point out, into
a problem of some, of a well-known, well
understood computer science problem, of finding the maximum
spanning tree. If we find the maximum spanning
tree. Then we have found the best dependency tree.
>> So, to be honest, I don't remember maximum spanning tree.
Minimum spanning tree, can we just solve a maximum spanning
tree problem by, I don't know, negating the edges or, or
>> Yes.
>> Adding, okay.
>> That's exactly right. So, everywhere in there, where you pick a max,
you pick a min or you just label them with the negative of
the mutual information and it's the same thing. I think that this particular
form of writing as a maximum mutual information, is easier to think about.
>> Okay.
>> And what you'll do when you find the maximum
spanning tree, is you'll end up with, in fact some tree. And you're done.
>> Well, so now you need to tell me, because
the structure was a directed structure. So, dude, so can
we then pick any node then call it the root
and then do a, like a depth first reversal or something?
>> Absolutely. So, first off, I want to point out
there's 2 different algorithms that you could use. Do you
remember the two algorithms you could use to find
the maximum spanning tree? Or the 2 famous ones anyway?
>> I'm going to go with Prim and Kruskal but I know there's others.
No, those are the two that, that they teach you in algorithms class. And
it turns out for this particular one, you want to use prim. Because, prim is,
>> Proper.
>> [LAUGH] It is proper, prim and proper. Prim is the proper algorithm to
use whenever you have a strongly connected graph, it just happens to be faster.
>> You mean densely connect to graph.
>> What did I say?
>> Strongly.
>> Okay, densely connected. Right, a densely connected
graph and by the way, this is a
fully connected graph, which is about as dense
a connected graph as you can get. [LAUGH] So,
Prim's algorithm runs in time quadratic or polynomial anyway in
the number of edges. And so it's actually fairly efficient
as things go, because as we know in theory if
it's polynomial, it might as well be free. There you go.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So use Prim's algorithm, you find
the Maximum Spanning Tree, and you are done.
>> Alright, I'm going to need reminding where
we, where this is all plugging in.
>> Okay.
>> because.
>> That's exactly what I was going to.
>> because, this is a cool diversion, but.
>> Right, so this is actually worth pointing out this
was a bit of a diversion that we had to
do. Let's go back to the original algorithm that we
had, and just point out what we would be doing here.